because in a feature film you know you
can have a you know
a four-hour movie and the last five
minutes can let it down and then
for the audience the whole experience
gets thrown out the window um
it's it's it's like the the end of an
anecdote or the punchline to a joke like
it
it justifies everything you've seen so i
always come up with the
the ending early on well i think you
know people who've seen my other films
um
they're gonna see things in this film
that i've been playing around with for
20 years you know the idea of a bullet
jumping out of the wall and going back
into the gun i mean i think the longest
i was stuck
the longest i was stuck was on inception
i you know i got to page
80 or so you know i had two acts of it
and i was stuck for about
i mean 10 years or so you know i've been
working specifically with the spy genre
and
with how to to incorporate these ideas
into that
that genre for about about six years now
uh specifically on tennis
we were looking for an aspect of
selflessness to the character
that in a previous spy fiction it's
really a genre thing you have these very
cynical hard-bitten protagonists
and it's a little bit at odds with the
concept of somebody who
in story terms is willing to give up
their life for their fellow human being
if there's something wrong with the
third act it's actually wrong with the
first and second act you know that's
where you really need to do the work
i have always found that to be true
so talk to me about how long this took
to
come to pass like i've read somewhere it
was a decade in your
mind this idea of tenet well i think you
know people who've seen my other films
they're going to see things in this film
that i've been playing around with for
20 years
you know the idea of a bullet jumping
out of the wall and going back into the
gun
i mean it's there metaphorically in in
momentum right back there
these are images and ideas i've been
fascinated by and looking to synthesize
into a form where
it's not structural it's not
metaphorical it's real it's it's what
the character's actually dealing with
it's concrete reality
and that's taken me a long time i've
been working specifically with the spy
genre and
with how to to incorporate these ideas
into that that genre for about
about six years now uh specifically on
tenants
it's taken a while it's it's a lot a lot
of thinking that's gone into it but um
it's been a fun ride um you said the
tenant brought things that you had been
thinking about for at least
20 years what was the moment you
realized that the script
was ready to shoot
well it was more a question of the
moment i realized
that the set of ideas was was ready to
commit to the page in screenplay form
um i won't sit down to write something
until i kind of know that i'm ready to
and the ideas are all in balance and and
that can take a very long time
i'm not somebody who does a lot of
multiple drafts over the years
i tend to just take notes and draw
diagrams and think about concepts and
sort of think about okay
how could you apply that to different
forms of storytelling what might the
screenplay be
but once i've kind of focused in on on
that set of ideas and i know i'm ready
to to put it into screenplay form
that's sort of the big leap for me and
then the screenplay is a sort of
jumping off point for the execution of
you know how you're actually going to go
and make it
so i remember reading at one point that
you had sort of done i think the first
two acts and then
maybe nathan you sort of talked about it
and you were like then you're going to
go into the third act like do you
how do you sort of tend to write this
the script do you sort of go through one
pass
i go through linearly um
so i write the script you know from the
first frame to the last frame
and i tend to build up the drafts as i
go so i tend to rewrite
you know as i add a scene i'll very
often go right back to the beginning of
this
script re-write through and then add the
next scene and sort of layer it that way
every write is different everybody does
it differently um
that process works for me because i've
done so much planning before i write the
screenplay right
so i i know you know where you're going
i know where i'm where i'm going in
in the sense of the narrative movements
the narrative ideas
uh but yeah i sort of rewrite as i go um
and every now and again and this is one
of the only times i had to do you know i
had to involve nathan
at an early stage in a design set so i
only i'd only got two thirds of the way
through so i
i made him read that which was a bit
unfair uh and then
you know carried on a month later or
something i showed him the whole thing
a simple question but how did you select
the title
tenet and i'm curious sort of in the
name but also in your
creative process like the the name of a
movie when does that come to you is it
early or late
i usually have an idea early on
sometimes
a long time before in the case of tennet
i had the title very early i mean years
ago
and obviously the the the fact that it's
a palindrome
uh you know was the the sort of jumping
off point but it was also
um what the word means it's the notion
of
i have for you is a gesture in
combination with a word
tenet and for those who've seen the film
haven't seen the film um and i try to be
reasonably spoiler free
but uh because a lot of people are just
getting the opportunity to see the film
now
but for me that when you watch the film
there's a sense in which we're
addressing the idea that we're all
sort of imprisoned in a way in our own
views of the passage of time of what's
going on in the world all the rest
and so there is this kind of leap of
faith to the idea of an objective
reality
um so there's there's the idea of belief
or faith
involved with what these characters
choosing to invest in in terms of
what's really going on uh in the story
and that was always an intriguing idea
to me and i wanted to be right
you know up front on screen the
protagonist john david washington's
character a lot of people have been
wondering um
why you decided to hide or not go into
um his background
we know very little of his past what did
he do before becoming a spy
i know we're gonna get an answer to that
but no no the point is to not answer
that
uh i i really wanted to tap into that
kind of great tradition of
the anonymous protagonist um i mean for
me it dates back to
to uh you know the tv show the prisoner
for example
yeah um where he's known by a number or
the number he resists
number six you know known as the
prisoner um but also
uh i was thinking a lot of sergio leone
westerns like clint eastwood is
you know the man with no name all the
rest i think there's something
for me there's something really
compelling about
jumping into uh a story
and being told essentially to
concentrate on the here and now
to pass through this experience in the
present tense
ironically it's a film that deals with
time but it's really important as you
watch the film that you're just kind of
looking over this guy's shoulder and
going with him
he's a very present tense uh presence in
the film and and so
deliberately not naming him not uh
including any of the information about
how we you know he might have arrived
there
i think hopefully draws attention to
that that idea and keeps people
really focused on the here and now uh
obviously john david and and
you know my discussions with john david
you know we we had to
you know have some sense he really
needed to have a
sense of who this guy was and where he'd
come from but we really didn't want that
uh specified in the movie i see so
you've developed some of that you know
kind of in your head and john does
a little bit of that but you're not
exposing it to the audience yeah we
weren't massively
pedantic about it we weren't going
through you know who his parents were
and where he was born and all the rest
but we needed to have a sense he needed
some guidance from me of
you know what's this guy's background
some of which is loosely indicated in
the script
yeah um you know the jumping off point
for the film he's clearly
you know working uh you know um the
secret service organization probably the
cia you know that and so forth
um but you know we want we talked about
the fact that for example he clearly has
a lot of military training and that that
kind of thing and
uh but we uh we didn't want to specify
any of that for the audience
but the actor needs to know the
underlying truth of the character to
make it a
a consistent characterization with the
protagonist
john david and i talked about this
character having an aspect of
we we would not in any way specific to
religion christianity but
in almost sort of spiritual terms we
talked about nina have faith
and the title of the film has that that
aspect to it and
um that was very much a sort of um
uh a subconscious thing really that i
think both of us as we approach material
we talked about
what to do with it we were looking for
an aspect
of selflessness to the character that
in a previous spy fiction it's really a
genre thing you have these very cynical
hard-bitten protagonists
and it's a little bit at odds with the
concept of somebody who
in story terms is willing to give up
their life for their fellow human being
fellow human beings and so we were
interested in
looking in a slightly different way and
thinking that there must be a
selflessness
call it that or some degree of
spirituality to this this character
and i think john david it was really a
question of not so much
putting in the script as having him uh
play the character with this
sort of i suppose you call it i guess a
generosity
of spirit that you don't normally see in
those characters and i think i think it
gave you
an interesting dimension seeing john
david
sort of center that film and carry the
audience with him
it was impossible for me to get get him
out of my head at that point because i
tried to write without actors in mind
but after i'd seen him in that film and
seen how as i say he
carried us with him on on that journey
it was very tough for me to to not think
of him while i was writing after that
and
and then i met him when i finished the
script and creatively
you know we just we just clicked i think
he has
this warmth and accessibility that's
extremely important
for the protagonist because what we're
trying to do there is create an iconic
presence at the heart of the film and
it's
it's it's something you can't approach
directly you can't
try and find an actor who will just be
an icon of
you know spy movies or whatever you have
to approach it in a different way and
look at
who the character needs to be and for us
and john dave and i were
really on the same page it it was about
removing the cynicism that these
characters are usually drenched in
because there's a paradox there you know
if you're looking at a character who
will lay down his life for his fellow
man or for an ideal or for an abstract
principle which is very often what these
characters are
saying they're prepared to do to us it
felt that that had to
encompass a degree of faith in in
humanity and
and a warmth and an uh feeling of
empathy
uh towards people around him and so
balancing that
with this this sort of um get things
done
there's this kind of ruthlessness as far
as the task at hand
i think he found a way to reconcile
those two
those two very different impulses and
and i think it
presents a really remarkable aspect to
the character i can feel the tender
affection between the conversation
attitude of protagonist and neil
did you explain to john and robert the
special relationship
between the two characters um
yeah i mean it's i think a lot of it was
there on the page for them actually
um but then once you you cast the film
uh because their relationship you know
as you watch the film it becomes
more and more important to the story i
suppose you'd say um
you know there are some ambiguities to a
relationship and then and then there's a
there's a camaraderie that develops it's
very important um
a lot of that was was indicated on the
page
but once you finish a script you then
look around and say okay who can play
these parts
you put people together um
and then you know you see the chemistry
that develops and and these guys
you know john david and rob pattinson um
you know they just connected and it
really really
for me it just just worked with what we
were trying to do with with the story
it's really fun to watch these guys work
together and it's
i think it's really fun to watch the the
characters interact in the movie
once you know how do characters return
to their original timelines
after traveling backwards um there's
obviously a lot going on with um
you know characters moving different
timelines i assume the question is sort
of
um you know yeah how do they do they go
back to their original timeline or do
they stay on that timeline
well the question slightly
misunderstands
the rules um their timeline is their
timeline
and through the rules of inversion it it
can be inverted and they can move
backwards through time they can then
reinvert
using a turn style and then start moving
forwards in time but they will
continue to be uh on that timeline
right so it's also easier to draw a
diagram it's also one timeline it's
one uh the best way to think of it and
and this
relates to the earlier question is if
you look at john david's experience and
you follow him through the entire story
yeah that's a single timeline that
you're following
but that timeline can move both forwards
and backwards and that's
where i was interested in these this
this rule set
uh because it's quite distinct from
time travel per se or time travel movies
where multiple realities or something
like that exactly
and they refer to the possibility of
multiple realities but the
terms of the storytelling are pretty
tight in that you follow
this character and you're looking over
shoulder the whole way and you're
you're experiencing his timeline on how
that can meander forwards and backwards
you know time is uh
is something that we can tell you have a
fascination with
over a number of films where do you
think that comes from where does that
fascination and interest and intrigue
come from
well i'd like to say i'm fascinated by
time because i've always lived in it
and it's a big glimpse but there's
real truth to that though because we we
are all obviously living in time and
living with time and it's one of the
things that
causes us it's one of the biggest
influences on our lives the biggest
influence probably and yet
we're unable to fully understand it
we're unable to really grasp it or even
explain what it is quite frankly
and that's fascinating to me it's one of
the great enigmas that
that we all have to deal with every
second of our day
and the relationship between that
subjective experience of time and the
way
the ways in which we experience time
changing
at different points in our lives
different points in our day
the relationship between that subjective
experience and
the mechanism of cinema and how shot
following shot following shot
builds up a narrative experience in the
minds of the audience you sit there in a
cinema and you you receive a story in
roughly two hours
but the time span of that story can be
it could be
minutes to centuries to millennia you
know it's
it's it's all possible and that's a
fascinating relationship and
the mechanism whereby that relationship
is exploited or takes place to me is
fascinating and i like the idea of
exposing that mechanism and involving
the audience in you know
i suppose you'd say a discussion of that
mechanism just trying to make them
experience or notice
the way in which a movie is making them
feel for me tennis first and foremost
action film and the science fiction
component
gave me a reason to portray these action
set pieces that we've all perhaps
you know seen in other movies you know
whether it's a car chase or a
plane crash or circle to mount it on a
large scale but
look at it in a different way look at it
through a different lens and
for me as an audience member that's just
what i'm always looking for some kind of
freshness to things
so i want to enjoy a large-scale action
movie i want to go on that thrill
ride but i want something new out of it
i want i want to
look at it in a way that i haven't
before i use genre to try
and play with audience expectations i
don't mean play within a sort of
toying sense but in a sense of what can
a particular genre the conventions of a
genre what advantage is going to give
you with
audience expectation and in dealing with
something as abstract and slippery as
time and
inversion of time having the the solid
structure of the spy film with the
expectations that that
presents to the audience and the
familiarity the familiar elements that
that gives the audience to hold on to
that lets me try and take the audience
places they've never been before
i mean 10 years ago with inception we
try to do that using the conventions of
the heist film
to explore dreams and dreams within
dreams and and so forth
and i think really this is you know for
me is a very similar thing i'm taking
the
the spy film genre and using it to
address
uh ideas of of time uh were there
multiple endings you thought of using
and had to decide from if so what were
some of them i know you know often the
ending for the film you'll think of
pretty early in the process of kind of
where you want to go but did you
were there other scenes or you know not
deleted scenes but sort of other
concepts of the end of the film i mean
no
the simple answer is uh i don't go into
a project without
knowing the ending because i think the
ending is uh
it's the most important part of feature
film i think
um i think that's one of the the things
that keeps feature films very distinct
from television
because in a feature film you know you
can have a you know
a four-hour movie and the last five
minutes can let it down and then
for the audience the whole experience
gets thrown out the window um
it's it's it's like the the end of an
anecdote or the punchline to a joke like
it
it justifies everything you've seen so i
always come up with the
the ending early on and and hopefully
it's something that
uh you know it has to be something that
emerges really specifically from the
story situation that you're examining so
no i don't sort of look at a
mixed bag of potential endings and then
sift through them
um the only time i've ever in in my work
i've ever had sort of had
as it were multiple endings is when i
made insomnia uh for warner brothers
years ago they
um they were very insistent that i shoot
an alternative ending
uh i don't want to give away the ending
in the film because a lot of people
won't have seen it and maybe they'll get
to enjoy it but uh
they wanted me to shoot two different
endings and i agreed to do that
and uh fortunately because i'd shot this
alternate ending they never asked to see
it they knew it was in the care
and then they let me you know test
screen the the ending we all we all
loved and we went we went with that but
uh
that's really the only time i've been in
a situation where there was possibly
going to be an
alternate ending that's not generally
something i'm comfortable with at all
um speaking of the ending another
question from twitter
uh did you make a casablanca reference
in neil's last
scene louie
i think this is the beginning of a
beautiful friendship
for me i think this is the end of a
beautiful friendship but for me it's
just the beginning
well i don't want to have it i don't
want to have any spoilers for people who
haven't seen the film
yes there's very much a casper reference
in the last scene
excellent hi everyone thank you all for
watching
if you'd like to see more advice from
christopher nolan look into the
description of this video
where you will find the link to 10 tips
from his other films
also in the description there is a link
that will lead you
to our patreon page where you can
support this channel
and watch 5 extra screenwriting and
directing tips from christopher nolan
among with other videos that we don't
share anywhere else
see you all next week have there been
times working on a script
that you thought that you'd never be
able to complete it you have that
writer's block
i every day on the script uh yeah
definitely i mean it's something any
writer deals with
a lot every problem always seems
insurmountable the
the cruel thing the cruel trick that
your mind plays on you when you when
you're writing is
you sort of go to bed at night
thinking oh i've got the whole thing
worked out and i can write it no problem
tomorrow and then you sit down and
you're like hang on
it seemed so simple till i started
writing it
and you're often getting stuck i mean i
think the longest i was stuck
the longest i was stuck was on inception
i you know i got to page
80 or so you know i had two acts of it
and i was stuck for about
i mean 10 years or so you know i mean i
did other things as well i wasn't
sitting here the typewriter all work and
no play yeah it wasn't that
but you know i was i was just jammed on
it uh
and then i had a breakthrough uh and
the old cliche of if you're having
trouble
if there's something wrong with the
third act it's actually wrong with the
first and second act you know that's
where you really need to do the work
i have always found that to be true like
if you if you're absolutely stuck
you know on that third act it probably
means that some of the ground work you
laid in the first two acts
is flawed somehow and with inception
that was definitely the case and i went
back and
with a new take on it and it uh it then
got finished pretty rapidly
you